نا الى هنا بالقرب من شارع الرشيد الذي
تسيطر عليه قوات الاحتلال من الشمال
الغربي لمدينه غزه هذه المنطقه القريبه من
الميناء القديم تعرضت الى غاره جويه عنيفه
ادت الى تدمير مربع سكني عدد كبير من
المنازل اصبحت كوم من الركام واعداد كبيره
من الشهداء والجرحى تم انتشالهم وما تجا
وما تزال طواقم الدفاع المدني تحاول
العثور على اعداد اخرى لان شهود العيان
يتحدثون عن عدد كبير ما زال تحت هذا
الركام يعطيك العافيه الله يعافيك يا ابو
حمز شو انت سكان هذه المنطقه انا احد
الساكنين في هذا المنطقه وهذا المنزل الي
تدمر بشكل ايش اللي صار امبارح السبت
الساعه عه ربع تقريبا فاجانا بقوه انفجار
هائله جدا
اي
صاروخين هم برميلين
متفجرين ارتقى على يعني على اثرهم من
عائلتي عائله ابو حصيره ما يقارب من 20
الى 25 شهيد ومن عائله الجوجو تقريبا سبع
شهداء التدمير او القصف يعني دمر حي كامل
كان كانت هذه المنطقه تعتبر من امن
المناطق في انت مين راحلك انا استشهد من
عند زوجتي وابني في الصف الثاني ابتدائي
وبنتي في في مرحله البستان يعني في مرحله
بدايه الدراسه اه وعمي حمايا وحماتي
ونسايب اربعه وعم زوجتي وبنات عم زوجتي
ثلاثه كنتم متوقعين انتم بصراحه لا بصراحه
لا يعني كان الامر مفاجئ مباغت يعني قض
على كل شيء في حياتنا اي مع العلم انه
يعني عم زوجتي وبناته واولاده ونساي
هم اصلا نزحوا من منطقه تل الهواء منطقه
تل الهواء بيوتهم كلها هناك تدمرت يعني في
ناس من اللي نزحوا من تل الهوا راحوا
نزحوا من تل الهواء يعني هربوا من قدر
الله الى قدر الله نزحوا من منطقه الهواء
من الموت ويعني ولقوا حتهم في هذا المكان
اللي يعني كله مدنيين كله اطفال كله نساء
كله يعني من كبار من كبار السن لا حول ولا
قوه الا بالله هذا هو زميل صحفي يعني في
صحيفه فلسطين هنا في قطاع غزه وكما
تلاحظون هذه المنطقه تحولت الى ركام كبير
ما تزال طواقم الدفاع المدني تعمل من اجل
العثور على عدد كبير ما زال تحت انقاد هذه
المنازل التي تحولت كما تشاهدون الى هذا
الشكل بالتاكيد عشرات من المنازل المجاوره
ايضا تضررت بحيث لم تصبح صالحه للسكن كما
تش شاهدون وهو الامر الذي يحدث في كل
الغارات الاسرائيليه التي تستهدف مناطق
تعتبر مكتظه بالسكان هذه المنطقه من اكثر
المناطق اكتظاظا بالسكان هي صحيح ليست
كالمخ مات ولكن هذا جزء من المشهد الحاصل
في قطاع غزه سواء في مدينه غزه تل الهواء
الزيتون الشجاعيه والرمال والشاطئ هذه
الغاره حصلت تماما بعد سي الوابل كثيف من
قنابل الفسفور التي استهدفت مخيم الشاطئ
شمال غرب مدينه غزه وكما تلاحظون هي
بالتاكيد واحده من الغارات لكن بالتاكيد
هناك غارات كثيره ربما تسببت في دمار يفوق
هذا الدمار الحاصل هنا في هذه المنطقه
وائل الدحدوح الجزيره غزه فلسطين